tonight House lawmakers are getting
their first look at a massive 1.3
trillion dollar government spending
package facing a Friday night deadline
to get it done
Republican leaders say it will make the
strongest investment in the military in
15 years and will help with readiness a
Georgia Republican who serves in the Air
Force Reserve says that investment is
pretty you've seen the military
emaciated like it was under
sequestration also then the Obama
administration's what I feel is very
poor military decision we're seeing that
coming to payback now the funding bill
also includes a 2.4 percent pay raise
for military personnel the White House
and Democrats traded offers over the
weekend on addressing the so-called
dreamers that included a White House
request for 25 billion dollars for the
border wall in exchange for extending
daca until fall of 2020 Democrats said
no they want the issue not the solution
so they're rejecting it we're trying to
get to a funding bill that will carry us
through the rest of the fiscal year
Democrats demanded a path to citizenship
in exchange for fully funding the wall
and talks hit a dead end
but one of the top Senate Democrats
signaled his members are not drawing a
red line on this issue we're not going
to have a shutdown but I'm urging the
leaders to basically come together and
understand there is an emergency at hand
here 780,000 young people have their
lives hanging in the balance because
President Trump killed the daca program
most sources sound very optimistic they
will get it done but all acknowledge the
possibility there could very well be
drama before the deadline
Brett McMahon you live on the hill Mike
thanks